oh discouraged by the pandemic two-time
corporate translate champions
and foreign in this online era
will anything rise to the occasion and
not give off their high horse
find out
oh hello there welcome to the 2020
season of the corporate chess league
i'm alex kirford founder of the
corporate chess league
financial advisor and team captain of
edward jones
we are so happy that you are making the
adjustment to
virtual online corporate chess league
this year
and so happy to have more teams more
players and more
competition when we started out the
corporate chess league
we desired to have an opportunity for
networking
enjoyment of the game of chess and being
able
to come together and compete as
different companies glad that you're
here with us
today and looking forward to more games
to come
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the
uh 2020 corporate chess league this is
event
five of six here today and as such there
have already been four events in the
books
and i wanted to introduce uh the show by
showing where we stand
right now uh all six events count
towards the grand prix
and the current standings you can
actually see to my left here
we have edward jones soaring atop the
leaderboard
with 244 points and then it's
relatively tight after that we have
ascension uh worldwide technology
merits bayer all uh with 112 through 125
points
and express scripts and enterprise not
that far behind with 89 and a half
points and 83 points
and then daherty i don't believe is
actually competing today
and so i think their chances of making
the playoffs are pretty slim
and that's right i just said playoffs
there is of course
a final match in december between the
top four teams at the end of the grand
prix
so a lot to play for here with i think
all 17
all seven teams having a very decent
chance to get into that grand prix
uh final in december so
with that in mind let's take a look at
our format for today
uh it is as i said event five of six
in the 2020 corporate chess league the
time control
as always is game in 10 minutes with a
zero
second increment so that's right no
extra time
no delay none of that garbage only fast
10 minute chests if you get flagged you
get flagged
round one is actually getting underway
here already
uh and each round consists of a two-game
match so players will play their
opponent with the white pieces
once and once with the black pieces in
both rounds
uh the way that these grand prix points
are awarded is actually pretty
interesting
if your team wins the match against the
team they're paired against
your team is awarded 20 full grand prix
points
if your team draws with the other team
you're awarded 10 grand pre-points
but then the twist is that your total
board points
are also awarded as grand prix points
now what does that mean that means every
individual point
that is scored every game that is won or
drawn
those are points that go directly
towards that team's total
and this is how we see teams like edward
jones running up such a big score they
just have so much participation
so much participation such a big team
that they can
sort of get all these board points added
to their totals
and of course as i said the top four
teams at the end of the grand prix
are going to advance to the final
without further ado let's take a look at
today's pairings
this is our round one match-up we have
edward jones against
bayer we have ascension against
enterprise and we have express scripts
against worldwide
technology merits by the way is getting
a first-round
buy but that's not such a big deal they
with their three players are playing the
overflow
players mostly from edward jones
and if they manage to win the majority
of those games
more than 50 they will be awarded the
full 20
points that they normally would have
been awarded for playing a match
uh and they actually have already
secured 10 points
by virtue of getting the buy so what
matchups am i looking
uh looking at here well of course we
always have to follow edward jones
and bayer is right on that cusp of
making
that final match in december so we'll
definitely keep an eye on them
merits we will have to keep an eye on as
well they have one of the
smallest teams here tonight but they
have a very very strong team as well
with their team leader maybe swap coming
in at 1886 rating
and their board two by the way the one
the only
mike cummer that's right mike cummer is
playing for merits and he is their board
too
definitely a team you're gonna have to
look out for
and they're aboard three by the way no
pushover either i am rounder 1601
so despite them having the fewest
players on their team
i expect them to do well in the
head-to-head matchups
by the way mike was giving me the scoop
before the round started here today
and he let me know that edward jones has
actually never been defeated
in a head-to-head matchup so we'll see
maybe
tonight is the night that they get taken
down well
the round as i said is already getting
underway here so why don't we check out
some games
i'm going to flip over here and let's
see if i can pop these things open
let's see it looks like board
one for edward jones is where we're
gonna start out
uh start off with and that is vishal
bharadwaj
which is not the easiest name in the
world for me to spell but i will do my
best
i will do my best here
and yeah we do have the games underway
and my goodness
are they underway this game is already
almost over
um interestingly the shells chess.com
rating is only 800 but don't let that
deceive you he's bored one
of edward jones for a reason and what is
going on in this position well it looks
like vishal
is actually up a full pawn here
but what's this after h4 it looks like
d4
is actually coming under fire can black
just capture this pawn
it looks like uh he can and has captured
this pawn
and if i'm playing with the white pieces
here i'm a little bit nervous to be
honest it looks like my king might
actually be
a bit more open than blacks and this
knight on e5
is a little bit loose this rook here on
c1 is also very loosely defended
this queen is working overtime to defend
all the pieces
and if anything ever happens to this
queen look out because
either one of these pieces could be
captured so priority number one
especially in these fast time controls
for me
is making sure my pieces are safe and
secure
and we'll see if uh vishal is able to do
that here but
you know uh he's not interested in
security he's going g4
uh i expect he plans to go to g5 rip
open this king's side
and start launching some sort of crazy
attack
and and that'll definitely be one to
look for uh by the way black's last move
i'm not actually a big fan of
now i'm starting to wonder if white is
actually going to be the one
playing for some checkmates here with
queen to e4
lining up the queen with the bishop
aiming at this loose h7 point
probably for that reason we do see
essentia going for
queen d4 here offering up a trade of the
queens
trying to make sure there are no
checkmating threats michelle though
not interested not interested in the
slightest
in accepting that queen trade goes queen
g3
should be a fun one here should be a fun
one
and by the way hello hello to everyone
joining us in the chat here
uh as always my name is caleb i don't
think i introduced myself at the top of
the hour
and i am going to be covering all of the
action here today
to start off with once again we are
looking at the board one matchup between
edward jones
and bayer here and as i've said edward
jones
while they have pretty much fully
secured their uh spot in the finals
bayer is on the cusp so bear is going to
look to uh perform well here tonight
and get themselves in better position to
secure that spot in the december finals
and yeah as i mentioned these pawns
are coming up the board and white now
has a pawn on
g6 and the question is going to be
will white be able to use this pawn to
checkmate
or will this g6 pawn find itself falling
off the board
whenever you push a pawn so far up the
board like this way into enemy territory
it's true that it can be a useful
attacking piece guarding really
important squares
but it can also end up a little bit weak
right they don't call it enemy territory
for nothing
this is where black's pieces all reside
and we see this pawn is already under
pressure from this bishop
if this e pawn ever moves out of the way
it'll be under pressure from the queen
as well
and white might regret pushing this guy
so far up the board
what am i talking about though none of
that matters white is playing for
checkmate he's playing for tactics
he's highlighting the fact that this
knight is loose here on the d3 square
but if i didn't know any better i'd say
knight takes f2 was playable in that
position
if i didn't know any better i'd say
knight f2 rook takes d8 knight e4 is a
check
and attacking a queen the rook is still
attacked
i think black may have missed an
opportunity there instead though
essentia here going after this c4 pawn
and my only concern is that yes it's
it's great to pick up
pawns but maybe it's not so good when
you could be getting checkmated on the
board
we actually see black repeating the
position which is pretty interesting
here
maybe he's spotted knight takes f2 and
is hoping white will repeat
but i don't think this is the best way
to go about things because
vishal is you know under no obligation
to play the move rook d1 here
uh and yeah i want to check out more
games but i almost want to stick with
this one because this is
exciting interesting stuff yeah queen g5
and this move is perhaps setting up a
queen h5
queen h7 threats when black may
may just get checkmated so very severe
threats
being uh executed here on the board
there is a knight takes f2 idea again
with the bishop on b1 hanging i'm not
sure if it was good though
uh once again perhaps black needs to be
more worried about getting checkmated
than anything else here
and queen h5 arrives on the board and we
actually see a peace sacrifice
by black not what uh
not what essentia was hoping for i'm
willing to bet okay with that extra
piece i'm willing to say
white has pretty good chances here black
might be able to hold
a draw if he gets a lot of pressure
especially against
f2 manages to trade off some pawns uh
there are some chances but i'm going to
be honest with you this one looks
pretty good for white knight g5 coming
in next
should be a victory for vishal all right
let's check out
board two of edward jones versus bayer
that is going to be alex kirford the
league commissioner
the man you saw at the top of the hour
doing the introductions
and what do we have here alex is under
quite a bit of pressure
uh all of his pieces can find these
first few squares
he breaks out with a queen trade this
rook is under attack
though e6 is under attack i don't think
there's gonna be a good solution here
for alex
that being said two minutes for white
three minutes for black definitely
anybody's game
uh information about the format i did
briefly go over it at the top of the
hour
but once again there are two rounds
being played here tonight
it is a head-to-head team match-up style
uh tournament so right now we're looking
at all of the games
between the team of edward jones against
the team of bayer
they are two of the strongest teams in
the event edward jones i think
quite clearly the strongest and they are
on the cusp of
making the finals in december um and so
we're gonna play
two games per round each player gets one
white and one black against their
opponents
and we'll see who comes out on top alex
by the way
plays rook d6 sacrifices the exchange
and the e6 pawn
definitely it is white for choice here
a6 is also hanging
but what's this king f1 is stepping
right into the line of sight of two of
black's pieces
uh and once again i'm smelling some
tactics here some knight e4
and if you don't take this knight well
if you do take this knight i'll
take this pawn and if you try and get
fancy
play some rook takes d5 you might get
shocked by a knight g3 check
still a knight g3 check and this king is
running out of squares after f3 has to
go to e1
and definitely not without threats for
alex here
huge swindling opportunities if i had to
put a word to it
this is a position ripe for swindles
that being said white is staying calm
staying collected and collecting some
pawns
looks good for eagle eye
and with that we have one game that
looks good
for edward jones on board one one game
that looks good for bayer on board two
and i'm actually seeing some results
come in here
it looks like some of the first games
are already finishing so let's
take a look on down the line here
between edward jones and bear
we have kingtaker1324
uh trying to mess me up with those
numbers there but let's see what's going
on
in his game
one three two four he did mess me up
with the numbers how dare he
how dare he not know how to count
and it looks like they're actually
already on to round two king taker
taking home the first point for edward
jones and now he's
facing uh now this is just losing
for bayer and this one is a little bit
more of a rating mismatch than we've
seen in the first two
i think the first two were fairly close
michelle in the senship both 1800
alex and eagle eye both 1600 but now
down here
we have 1600 king taker playing now this
is just losing
for bayer and this is really the
strength of the edward jones team
their roster goes deep and i mean it
goes
deep they have so many strong players on
their team
uh you have to go all the way down to
board
one two three four five six
below they get before they get below
1400
and to be honest 1400 is is not so weak
in this event
uh okay so what's going on in this uh
game first and foremost what's this the
b7 pawn has disappeared from the board
ah yeah and this is a common idea in
these queen
pawn openings when you see the pawn in
front of the queen getting pushed
here we have what's known as the slav
where after c4
pressuring this pawn we have c6
defending this pawn
and then black goes for an early
development of this bishop this is a
huge advantage
to not moving this e pawn early on
however it does come with a downside and
that downside
is that this bishop used to be defending
this pawn on b7
and after it comes out to f5 black does
have to be rather cautious
that nothing bad happens on the square
in the game we saw some development
and actually a trade of the bishop for
the knight a trade on d5 and now
unfortunately for black
this queen is attacking two pieces at
the same time
not so easy to stop uh by the way
taking a look it looks like in those
first two games we did get the results
we expected eagle eye defeating alex and
vishal
defeating essentia and they're both on
to round two as well
and white picking up this pawn picking
up another pawn on d5
and now taking over the center with pawn
to e4
the huge downside whenever you do go
upon hunting like this in the opening
is that your queen can end up a little
bit offside sometime
although sometimes all the way on b7 and
not only that
you do have to spend quite a bit of time
capturing these pawns
if i'm black i'm looking for an
immediate way to get after this king on
e1
if i can't pressure this king and white
gets castled uh then black's just gonna
be two pawns down and that is not a
pleasant
time so moves like queen i5 check
definitely on my mind i don't know if
it's enough
probably knight c3 for white just
blocking the diagonal
but then maybe bishop c bishop b4
increasing the pressure
don't by the way don't forget rook b8 at
any moment can come through and perhaps
snag this pawn
off of off of b2
in fact why not rook b8 maybe queen a6
takes takes takes on b2 a lot of counter
play here for black i wouldn't count
this is just losing
out of the game uh just yet you know
even despite his name
even despite his name
so kaushik in the chat is asking how do
you qualify
for this events um well you
don't is the answer unless you are local
to st
louis and work at one of the local
st louis corporations it's going to be
tough it is a corporate chess league
made
for uh you know members of these
corporations to uh to test their chess
skills out against each other
uh okay let's move on to another game we
have
fishers of men on the board right below
king taker
and wow rook c8 not a huge fan of this
move
uh it does just allow white to get
castled i believe
and as i said if white gets castle then
he should be very very happy
okay rook v8 is the natural follow-up
but what's the plan after queen
to a6 what's the plan i think you have
to trade these queens
and then your rook on c8 is actually
going to be attacked
you might regret putting this rook here
after all
oh i i was guessing moves i didn't mean
to do that but okay let's take a look
fishers of men okay queen b4 was the
idea but this seems a little bit slow
now
right a bit slow i'm noticing a loose
piece over here
noticing if i can kick this queen out of
the way
some a3 move perhaps i may be able to
just capture this guy
that being said black does of course
have his own play
rook b1 nice simple solid
uh just defending the pawn on b2
but gosh this position is i
i think the best word for it is is nerve
wracking here this queen
on a6 just feels so off sides
it does have one path to retreat uh
via the d3 square so maybe white is just
up some clean pawns here but if black
can find some way
somehow to exploit this queen that's the
path to victory for this is just losing
i don't see it though good for white
moving on
we have fishers of men who
i am unable to follow oh and i'm unable
to follow because fishers of men
believe it or not has defeated his
opponent 2-0
already already he has won both of his
games against bio proto
so looking very good for edward edward
jones early early on
uh next up we have mikuez for edward
jones
let's take a look mike
and what's going on in this game in
round one mike
was actually able to win already and
this is a fairly close matchup
i'm noticing on the board by the way
that is a
skewer both rooks going to be under
pressure here
and no way to save both pieces
that being said white does have some
good positional edges going on here
this knight on d5 is a very very
powerful piece
and look out for tactics with this
knight leaving and the queen appearing
on d5
uh checking the king and attacking this
rook on a8
also look out for moves like rook b7
that being said i do have to pick black
here
because you know rooks are worth more
than bishops it's just that simple
sometimes
also by the way take a look at those
clocks almost eight minutes
for me and nearly two minutes left
for uh m c i
c h j m good luck mcnick jim
mcnick j mick nick jm final answer
and what in the world is going on
rook takes e5 is the move that's
mcnick comes up with this one is a
little over my head
i don't quite understand what is
happening here
but looks like some fireworks to be sure
that being said a rook is a rook and i
gotta k gotta pick maquez
in that game for edward jones all right
let's move on down
the line we have dn274
uh and what is going on with
dn274 honestly i have no
idea i think maybe both of their games
are actually
over
yeah i think both of their games are
actually over i'm only seeing one score
reported so far
but maybe they're actually between
rounds you never know so let's move on
to the final board for edward jones
which is
10 john what's going on on the bottom
board here
and 10 john actually went down in the
first round to cross the pj
and we have a pretty interesting
position going on here it looks like
black went for some clown pushes on the
king's side
you know clown pushes of course not an
offensive term
just meaning you push like a clown you
know no thought required go after the
guy
put on the pressure i love it and that's
what he does here he
also has taken a huge amount of space in
the center
that being said space always comes with
downsides by pushing the pawn so far
black has made a pretty big weakness
here on the e5
square and it's going to be tough to
keep a hold of this pawn
that being said h4 could end up a little
bit loose
and if black can make use of this huge
central advantage then white is going to
be under a lot of pressure
uh who do i actually think is winning
this game it's honestly anyone's guess
at this point
i do like where white's queen is at
offering
some annoying little pressure against
black's queen side
if i'm black i'm looking to play moves
like king b8 keeping things nice and
solid
but honestly b4 b5 knight takes e5
these are threats that are not easy to
stop the idea of b4 b5 of course
to hit this knight make it move out of
the way which would
undefend the e5 pawn and make life
for black very very difficult um looks
looks tough looks tough for 10 john here
across to pj
perhaps playing above his rating here
scoring some
very badly needed points for bayer
as i said bayer is actually currently in
fifth
place in the total grand prix standings
they are just
three and a half points behind merits
three and a half points
if they can leapfrog merits here tonight
they will be
in position to advance to the finals
it's the top four teams that move on
so bayer needs every point they can get
tonight in order to qualify
for those finals
okay i do want to try and get to a few
more games
we will be doing a little bit of
analysis in between the rounds as well
i want to at least highlight everyone's
games uh
i want to highlight everyone's games at
least once i feel like that's
only only fair
but we'll see if i i managed to actually
pull it off let's check out what's going
on
uh in the ascension v enterprise matchup
with frank
tan frank
tan no
frank t tan they always get me with
these usernames
and yes this game is still in progress
frank t tan very much the underdog in
this matchup it looks like enterprise
has a
insanely strong top two boards board one
for enterprise
kamikaze knight is 2048 rated
according to these pairings and board
two chess hulky is 1904
those are some of the highest rated
players in the event i think
only worldwide technology with a 2000 on
board one and edward jones with the 2000
on board one
can even com come close to competing
with those those types of numbers
so very impressive top two boards from
enterprise so
really uh the lower boards are where
these matches are going to be decided
for them
so we'll keep an eye on those uh expect
their top two boards to always be doing
well
but then again stiff competition what's
going on in this position
well it's another double-edged end game
it looks like
black is sort of pinning all of his
hopes on this a pawn if
i can push this a pawn up the board to
a2 turn that thing into a queen
then of course black would be winning
that being said
the other side of the board the king
side and the center
is not looking great for frank t
tan if rook 1 to c7 this
g7 pawn is going to be under a lot of
pressure but he does have some ideas
like 98 some good defensive resources
and basically all frank needs to do here
is hold on
uh the best way i can describe these
positions is
kamikaze knight is sort of playing with
the timer and i'm not talking about the
chess clock
i'm talking about this a pawn this a
pawn puts a timer on kamikaze
it says you have one two three moves
to do something i care about or else i'm
gonna win the game
by making a queen and these are some
very stressful types of positions to
play
honestly with either side so we'll see
if frank can make this a pawn
you know score the touchdown get to the
a1 square
if he can i expect him to win if he
can't
then kamikaze does have a lot of
advantages on the other side of the
board
by the way king f2 i'm not sure i like
this move it is of course
good to get the king into the game when
it's an end game but it does allow a
takes b3
and it is sort of not you know sensing
that urgency
that i'm talking about right white has
to make something happen
or else black is gonna queen and king f2
is not the way to make something happen
okay rook b1 now by kamikaze knight
and this is getting in front of the pawn
uh this is of course you know
along the right tracks here but i'm
wondering why not rook a2
and push this pawn to b2 uh
even if this first b pawn dies
there is now sort of a backup b pawn
by the way with rook b1 white is now
taking a defensive approach to the
position
compared to the offensive approach i was
talking about with rook
1 to c7 now g4 and i think this might be
you know not the greatest mixing of
plans by
kamikaze knight here you know he would
love to go after the black king and
moves like g4
are saying that's what he's thinking
about but then you sort of need the
second rook
you can't really half commit to
attacking and half commit
to defending here if i'm frank t10 i'm
playing rook c8 i'm playing rook c2
playing b2 i'm playing rook a1 and the
game ends
how long does that take well it takes
one move to play rook c8
rook c2 is a check so the king would
move then a second move to play rook b2
and a third move to play rook a1 and
when you play rook a1
i think the game ends so h6 by frank is
a more defensive approach
but i think rook c8 may have just been
winning the game
kamikaze is sensing the danger now does
play rook c7
which i do like as a defensive move it
keeps
this rook on b8 from entering the
position which was
very very important definitely a back
and forth game to keep an eye on
by the way this game between the shawl
and essentia
was actually drawn by repetition in a
very crazy end game i think with good
play here it should in fact be a draw
but honestly these end games
can occasionally be very very difficult
for the knight
king taker again does end up winning
with those extra pawns
making his score 2-0 alex kurford
against eagle eye
is well into the second match up here
and again
it's not looking great for alex there
seems to be
uh some threats coming against his king
this bishop in this rook
working working very well together and i
think this is going to be a queen
sacrifice
from alex that being said
you know the game doesn't end when the
queen dies the game ends when the king
is checkmated
and i do once again see some swindling
opportunities here for alex i don't know
how he always gets these positions
where he always sort of has uh you know
a prayer
by swindling his opponent but i think he
does here as well
i'm talking queen takes rook bishop
takes rook and
pawn takes on a6 if he does this
then this pawn is two steps away from
becoming a queen
and if black has to give some material
back then
i think alex is going to be very much in
the game
uh so not as bad as it may seem at first
glance here for alex although of course
i do think eli
should be winning now can alex get away
with queen g3 here and picking up
even more pieces maybe but then
you know this b-pawn dies i just really
i
had hoped that this b-pawn would survive
the day
now a takes b5 maybe even queen h6 first
with some annoying checkmating ideas
and i think you know
things are sort of in the clear now for
for eagle eye
okay mcnick jim does end up winning this
game
what's that's not what i expected what
on earth happened
rook takes e5 oh and mikas
took the rook on b1 i think you have to
capture this rook on e5 here this rook
was very very dangerous making all sorts
of threats
and after queen b1
i no longer can see what happened
actually that's tough
uh so we'll come back to that game maybe
a little bit later but
after bishop b1 i think there is a rook
takes e7
and the game may have gone something
like this with
white now building up the pressure
against black's king that is a
tough tough break for miquez i liked his
position
across the pj by the way does win this
game
he did break through on the queen side
let's see
how he managed to do it he played knight
a5 clean back and actually lost a piece
but then these pawns did come and oh
the queen falls alright back to kamikaze
knight
this is the game i'm interested in and
boy oh boy has it progressed white
managed to pick up this pawn on b2
but what happened while black won a pawn
back in the center of the board in
exchange
a very complex end game here not
entirely certain
how that one is going to end up
um and in the meantime why don't we take
a look
at some of the other games that were
played
between ascension and enterprise
i feel like that's worthwhile um it
looks like some games are still in
progress
let's try and look at s gilmore999
see if this one is still going
and it is indeed we have been playing
big daddy jazz
64. 64 always a good chess number
and s gilmore did lose in the first
round but f5
is a pretty pretty tough move to look at
right this is
you know saying to this bishop where are
you going
by the way don't even think about taking
this with the pawn
this bishop is hitting this queen and
yeah best of best of luck to uh to white
meeting this move
there is a 96 idea but maybe queen c8
knight f8 you can even start taking
things
on the e4 square i don't know i think
maybe
h5 was the right idea for uh
black rather than f5 but s gilmore is
is really going for it here we have
queen f8
black will recapture white will capture
and black will capture again
and once again somehow these players are
finding themselves
in uh really the most complex endings
i've seen in a while
we have white with the extra exchange
here but
look out man these two pawns a4 a3
a2 a1 and again there is this idea
where white has to make something happen
before this pawn becomes a queen
a4 have to push the pawn here you just
have to push the the pawn push the
peshka as varakobian would say
gotta push the peshka okay as this game
develops it looks like we are in an
insane time scramble between frank tan
oh
and not that insane frank tan
unfortunately did end up
losing many many pieces here so we will
let that one simmer alex kirford by the
way is still
down the queen but with a rook and a
knight for it it does look like this
b-pawn ended up telling the story
of the game though gonna be tough for
alex to pick this one up
we might see some sort of crazy um
queen versus rook end game where the
rook
has some chances to actually hold on so
how could we get there you ask maybe
white wastes the turn
you see the move b2 knight d3 takes
takes and alex would get this pawn in
exchange for his knights
but on the other hand um
you know black of course gets gets the
queen for the rook
it's not always so easy to win that end
game though alex has something else in
mind he goes knight f7
heading for some checking squares i'm
not convinced this was the right idea
though
looks good for eagle eye again
all right moving on down the line we
have davinators
who split with his opponent moneyballin
we have oak ave
who defeated 21 gigawatts two to zero
uh why don't i actually flip over to
these scores as they're coming in here
i think the round may be coming to a
close this game with alex
i think is one of the last ones in
progress along with this one against
big daddy jazz uh so what happened here
we have uh the shawl going one and a
half to 0.5 for edward
jones uh alex curford uh
still holding on against eagle eye uh
still struggling in a queen versus night
end game
and overall looks like a victory for
edward jones king taker
going 2-0 fishers of men to el miquez
and dien
splitting their matches and only 10 john
losing both down at the bottom so far
okay ascension by the way tough
scores on the top two boards but this
was to be expected right we knew
that's uh that enterprise had
a tough top two boards so what's the
current score
the current score is three points for
ascension five for enterprise so
enterprise has actually secured the
victory here
so despite gilmore's best efforts in
this final end game that i'm flipping
back to
uh it looks like uh enterprise will be
taking home the match victory here
but gilmore with very good technique has
pushed these pawns up the board
i expect bishop c2 and then a2 and a1
is simply impossible to prevent
what else is going on well express
scripts by the way
did actually go down against worldwide
technology despite
an outstanding upset on board one
um and merits does win with
uh does actually win on the extra boards
here so they will be taking
home 20 match points for defeating
um the overflow players
20 full points for merits along with
those
board points that they have scored as
well
uh so what's going on here uh looks like
a free rook
and a free queen i fully expect gilmore
to win this game
okay he chooses not to take the rook
should still
absolutely be winning but you know i i'm
a fan of simplicity
and what's more simple than not having a
rook so
he does take this now we do see the
extra queen
and that's it guys i'm calling this one
for gilmore
if gilmore doesn't win this game i will
never commentate
another chess tournament in my life so
let's take a look back again
at these incoming scores as
they are finishing up here
um so we saw some of vishal's game
against essentia
he managed to go one and a half to 0.5
as we said alex split against
eagle eye what's what's okay i have to
see this
i have to see this alex managed to split
against eaglet winning this game down a
queen
on the clock alex with the dirty flag
wow that is not the result i expected
eagle like with 23 seconds here to win
the queen versus knight position
but he was unable to do it some
tenacious defense
from alex and yeah
wow by the way this time imbalance 1.8
seconds against 10 and a half seconds
and alex pre-moving like a madman
manages
to somehow someway outpace his opponent
here
defeating eagle eye down a queen gilmore
by the way has an official result now
he did checkmate big daddy jazz the name
just
makes me laugh can't help it and that is
the final result
of the round so flipping back over now
let's take a look
at these final scores
um so as we said vishal one and a half
uh to a half against essentia alex
somehow someway
getting that split against uh against
eagle eye here with one to one
king taker going 2-0 against this is
just losing
fishers of men defeating bio proto
didn't get a chance actually to see his
games
he just won too darn fast mcnick jim
splitting with miquez with an absolutely
bonkers rook sacrifice
that uh you know somehow someway ended
up opening a
in a critical diagonal for him dn274
splitting with vindy
don't think we got a chance to see those
games either again that the players
moving a bit too fast for me
and uh crass to pj defeating ten john
with two to zero so good result
for edward jones uh winning another
match
they do remain undefeated uh
in their lifetime record and
uh for ascension versus enterprise we
did see gilmore getting it done there
but it just
wasn't enough four points to five a
or sorry four points to six for
enterprise
a very close matchup actually
express scripts does end up losing to
worldwide technology um
and merits uh you know eeking out that
victory against
those overflow players boards one and
three getting it done but
mike mike what are you doing mike was
the ringer
and he ended up only scoring a half
point against his opponent
spirit which you know
i actually recognized this name i
recognized this name from the last time
i did commentary over this event
and spirik i think is is sort of known
for uh
scoring some some crazy upsets so
definitely a player to watch there
i believe for edward jones uh why don't
we go ahead and
take a look at how this affects our
standings
for today here is not where all the
teams stand
after one round let me double check see
what happened there
and sorry i shouldn't be scrolling
messing things up all over the place
and yeah those don't seem to be updating
quite as
expected um maybe
we'll give uh we'll give
nick here our wonderful tournament
director a little bit of time
to make sure those are all
up to date before we take another look
looks like he's actually updating them
now
um in the meantime maybe i will be able
to pull up some of those games we didn't
get a chance to look at
alex in the chat apologizing for his
dirty flag we saw it
we saw it we didn't see it live but i
did see the result and i just had to
check out what happened
but uh that was some some valiant
fighting there alex you were down
two seconds to 10 and still managed
to uh to win on time
so we do have updated standings i'm
being told
no we don't nick's a liar everybody
laugh at nick
none of these standings are working
right
okay no it's on my end it's on
my end the issues no it's not on my end
i have no idea what's happening
reference air that is tough
i hate to see it and it's fixed okay it
was on my end here are her standings
after the first round and what's this
we actually have a tie for the lead
edward jones is tied with worldwide
technology
this is not what i expected looking at
the scores
but it does look like worldwide
technology does actually have
as many board points as edward jones
which is impressive because i do think
they have one or two fewer players
so impressive result there enterprise
with 26 also getting it done
and merits with 24 and a half of course
they
had the buy and they did manage to win
the majority of their individual games
so they get the full 20 points plus four
and a half
board points looks funny because of the
extra games at the bottom
well we figured it out one way or
another and bayer with
15 and a half how did that happen
uh oh yes so they scored five and a half
board points and they actually have the
buy in round two so they have secured at
least 10 points
ascension with four and express scripts
with three and that is where we stand
after round one of two why don't we go
ahead and see
how this has affected our
grand prix standings
so this uh this is the total standings
now
after round one of two here we do see
ascension and
well actually ascension i think losing
in
that first round right to worldwide
technology
so merits has actually gained quite a
bit of ground on ascension
and put some distance between themselves
and bayer bayer will be looking
to win big in round two
in order to make up some of that ground
enterprise as well definitely not
out of it but definitely needs a win
here in round two to put themselves in
good position
to make that final in december once
again only the top
four teams will advance after the grand
prix
uh definitely one to look forward to
okay why don't we actually take a look
at the round
two pairings here are
the pairings for round two which
are ever so slightly cut off
and now they're not and
who do we have we have edward jones
facing ascension
is that correct what happened in round
one they placed
faced bayer and ascension barely lost to
enterprise
so wow very tough matchup for ascension
once again in those grand prix standings
ascension currently
currently sits in third place but edward
jones
undefeated in head-to-head matchups if
they actually take out ascension
that is going to be huge for the grand
priest standings that will leave the
door
wide open for enterprise to make up a
ton of ground
as well as merits and bayer to be uh
hunting for their position
by the way bayer again with the buy
in round two so if bayer can win the
majority of their games against these
overflow players
they will be getting the full 20 points
plus any board points
they they score so bayer perhaps with
the easiest match-up in this
final round of the nights and they're
going to be the ones gaining the most
ground
merits will have to defend their
position
in the top four against express scripts
who will definitely be looking to hunt
them down
and wow i think every matchup here is
going to be
absolutely critical if bayer will need
to actually win the majority of their
games enterprise will need to take out
uh worldwide technology they uh they
absolutely have to by the way
worldwide technology uh pretty far ahead
but if we do see them
you know sort of getting upset in these
rounds uh
you'll have to be on the lookout
anything could happen
setting us up for failure ah yeah you
know it's tough
by the way looking at board one for
bayer it looks like a pretty tough
matchup here
chessworm i do have some insider info
is our tournament director so i think
there was unfortunately a player who
had to drop out last second uh
and nick our tournament director filling
in he's no pushover i've lost chess
games to this guy
so look out essentia with a tough
matchup in
uh onboard one for bayer but they do
out rate their opponents on some of
these lower boards although definitely
not all of them so a match to look
forward to
to be certain
okay who should we follow first who
should we
follow first well i think we should
decide that
based on these grand prix standings
currently
so what's absolutely critical merits is
critical
bayer is critical enterprise is critical
these are the three teams that are
fighting
duking it out for that top four position
so i say we take a look at some of those
merits games there are only three of
them so shouldn't be
too too difficult on me and if they do
well
in those three matchups they secure
another 20 points
and most likely you know put themselves
in
a very good position heading into that
final day
so let's take a look the last round is
underway
here we go on your screen is oak live
against
miquez we're not going to stick here too
long because i do want to take a look at
some of these merits games
especially since we didn't see them in
round one we have maybe swap
on board one
let's jump to it maybe swap with the
black pieces here
and what is this opening what happened
let's take a look we had a bishop's
opening
and uh white playing some sort of
weird bishops opening not quite a vienna
and it looks like the point of white's
opening play was to point put the knight
on e2
rather than f3 why would white do this
well as you see in the game
white is actually looking to play this
move f4 a little bit early on
black responds with you know the
principled approach
when your opponent is sort of not
aggressively going after the center
early on
playing moves like knight e2 it's a good
idea for black to break in the center
early on
get after these central squares before
they have a chance to attack
but we do see now after some moves
white breaking with f4 black actually
just captures on
f4 not willing to deal with the pressure
bishop takes f4 and now we see a capture
on e4
a bishop check king h1 rookie 8 and we
are at the current position so what's
going on here
well the huge imbalance to look at is
this pawn on e4
and as i say that uh you know imbalances
who cares about those it's all about the
tactics here bishop takes h6
this knight on h6 finds itself
underdefended
okay maybe swap doesn't panic keeps the
moves coming this is the thing to do
in these fast time controls you just
have to keep playing no matter what
happens you cannot fall too far behind
on the clock
but uh as i was saying i do think i
prefer white here
thanks to this e pawn sometimes this
pawn can become a target with black's
rooks
ready to attack it but here i think it
just controls
too many squares it activates white's
pieces too much and we see a counter
sacrifice now
absolutely insane stuff
white says bishop takes h6 i'm opening
up your king
black says anything you can do i can do
better right just plays bishop takes h3
if we are gonna see a recapture here
then queen takes h3
is a check and look out queen h2 might
be playable but
all of white's pieces end up hanging at
the end of the day
no clue what's going on i think there's
some sort of capture
and night fork in the end we're not
gonna see it though black not willing
or sorry white not willing to capture on
h3 directly instead
goes for the pin on this knight black
saves the bishop with tempo now
and like i want to take a look at the
other games but this one is just
wild i want to stay here for just a few
moments
this one absolutely insane bishop back
to g4 okay where does the queen go
maybe over to d2 but it can be captured
maybe maybe queen d2 was was the right
idea there it would allow white to bring
in this piece
sort of with tempo but queenie one
played instead
that's another good square for the queen
and i'm finding it difficult to actually
suggest
moves here for either player we do see
the retreating bishop e7 a little bit
conservative
i was looking for ways actually in this
position
to get my rooks up and over and
checkmate this king
if a major piece for black lands on this
h file
white is in massive trouble instead
though bishop e7 we do see a trade
and things are starting to simplify a
little bit now i think black
is actually the one who is starting to
take over this position
if white can't get some sort of attack
going this pawn is going to be a
weakness
we now see a knight sinking itself into
the d3 square
black is likely looking to fill this e5
square with the bishop
and going after uh his opponent's queen
very
uh enterprising play
not from enterprise but from merits fun
stuff to watch let's take a look now at
the one
and only mike comer
if i spelled his name right i think i
did mike
playing on board two for merits is
uh heavily favored in this matchup but
what's going on here
mike with even material has castled his
king
and has good control over the only open
file on the board
and i do think that that means he has a
very good position
in this case queen a6 could be coming
attacking this bishop on d6
there's knight h5 but this bishop can
retreat back to h2 i don't see any
reason
why not and notably
black is the the way i can uh
best phrase what's going on here is
white is
owed chess moves what do i mean by that
well
white has already spent the time to
castle and activate this rook
meanwhile black's king still sits on e8
so black owes these moves black has to
castle at some point in this game
has to bring the rook in at some point
in this game has to move the queen off
the back row at some point in this game
and that is three moves ahead that mike
is black owes
three moves in this position before he
can comfortably say
he has achieved a quality and three
moves
is a lot of moves you know queen b8 is a
good start though queen b8
attacking this knight and actually
increasing the pressure on this diagonal
gives mike some uh some difficult
choices here
maybe knight f3 is called for to break
this pin and just taking back on h2
but with those moves being played it
does seem like
black is getting ever closer to this
equalizing idea of getting
the king castled and the rook into the
game
gonna be a close game here to be sure
and what's going on on board three from
merits we have i
am rounder let's take a look
i am runner against old loser
and this is a bit of a wild one here we
have a very unique
setup where there are actually no pawns
occupying
the center of the board this is as open
of a center as you can get
what does that mean well it means it's
time for the bishops to shine
with no pawns in the center blocking the
vision of these bishops they can control
a massive amount of squares
and here i do think it's black's bishops
that are going to be slightly better
placed to do this
that being said white is making some
concrete threats applying pressure
to black's setup here and after h6
expect this bishop to come back to f4
and yeah black has some weaknesses
that uh he'll have to contend with here
that being said black could immediately
start taking pawns if he felt the desire
i'm not convinced it's very good
but it is possible why
why am i not convinced well because
giving up this bishop for this night
just feels so
so sad this bishop is amazing this
knight
is less amazing maybe a simple move rook
c8 here
for i am rounder is enough sometimes
simplicity is
good your pawn is attacked you can
defend your pawn
why not why not
indeed but this game
a lot of chess left to be played by the
way k muni has already
won his game against uh or actually mace
maybe swap has actually already won his
game against
k muni maybe swap of course board one
for merits so off to a good start for
merits
what else is critical well bayer's game
is critical
but actually i don't want to spend too
much time on them because we did see
their games
in the first round who didn't we see in
the first round well we didn't see these
express
scripts players we actually didn't see
worldwide technology
who is playing against enterprise so of
course enterprise
with another critical match up here we
will definitely have to take a look at
those games
so uh board one for them kamikaze knight
do i still have
kamikaze knights game up on my screen
i'm
not convinced that i do
i do have
this game but nobody cares about that
game
this is always the toughest part
is keeping track of the insane amount of
games here
okay here's kamikaze 9th game up against
mjc
3801 for worldwide technology
and looks like a tough position
for mjc
material is still technically even but
if you look at how black's pieces
are you know the the unfortunate state
they find themselves in i think it's
pretty clear
that uh kamikaze knight is firmly in
control of this position
in fact i wouldn't be surprised if we
saw some pieces dropping off the board
for mjc pretty soon without too much
controversy here
how can you try to hold on maybe knight
f5 but i don't
see if it really really helps the point
is after rook e8 you can
take off this bishop which relieves some
of the pressure on this knight
but i just don't see how black is ever
going to untangle here this is sort of
almost a permanent grip on the position
for
kamikaze knight looks tough for mjc
looks good
for enterprise although as i've said
before enterprise their strength is
these first
two boards and below that
is where they are going to have to duke
it out
okay up next we have to take a look at
chess hulky against dv dutch i don't
think we actually saw
chess hulky's games in the first round
we definitely didn't see dv dutch
so let's take a look uh and wow chess
hulky
already with a point to the good
point to the good here but dv dutch with
a pretty reasonable position here
in the second round uh it is an isolated
queen's pawn position or iqp for short
what does that mean it means we have
this pawn in front of the queen
and it has no friendly pawns around it
to help support it
making it isolated what does that mean
well it means it's a little bit
vulnerable to capture because it cannot
be defended by other pawns
and in this position db dutch i do think
is just
capturing this pawn outright dv dutch by
the way
um uh a long time member of
some of my classes so rooting for him
here in this game
i don't mind showing a little bias for
those members of the corporate chess
league who have been
watching my lectures i hope they are
useful
and they show it by defeating their
opponents that being said of course
i wish chess hulky the best in this
event as well
and he's already won one of the two
games
here though how will chess focus
hulky defend this pawn on d4 i don't
think he can
i don't think he can in general in these
isolated
queen spawn positions white is supposed
to be going for some sort of killer
attack against the king
just not so easy to manufacture such an
attack here
so how do we find counter play let's try
and figure it out maybe queen b3
is the answer if rick takes d4 bring
this other rook over to d1
uh and take control of this file
also make some threats against the b7
pawn looks like knight c5 coming
it's going to be tough for white to be
sure but chess hopefully definitely not
out of the game even if this pawn on d4
falls off the board
up next let's see big daddy jazz against
sweet man
sweet man with a random one in his name
they all have
like their names are all almost so so
easy but then they have like one thing
that always trips you up
and looking good for big daddy jazz not
looking
as i said looking good for big daddy
jazz i said that just because i counted
the number of queens but black is like
checkmated here
this is insane this is absolutely insane
i may have to award this game the
brilliancy prize by the way
there's a brilliant surprise for this
event winner gets a lesson with me
black one by resignation oh this is a
fork
oh all right
i'm not convinced that white should have
resigned
i think um if king h5 and queen takes
bishop
okay maybe maybe it was resignable but
wow
very valiant effort by sweet man there
almo very very nearly
checkmating big daddy jazz in an
absolutely obscene position
but brilliancy prize remains up for
grabs still
definitely that game would have been a
hot contender
would have been a hot contender but
big daddy jazz takes home that point for
enterprise and that is a huge point for
enterprise
that is their board three and that's
where i think they they start to
struggle right they're boards one and
two
super super strong no worries they're
bored three and below
they're gonna have to uh have to fight
it out let's check out their board for
in the form of moneyballin here
moneyballin
and moneyballin is up against whedon 80.
who maybe josh whedon potentially
i don't know i don't know enough to
match the chess.com usernames
to the people but of course this one
looking good for moneyballing don't
think i can spend too much time here
looks like an extra piece how did he get
this extra piece
with some tic tacs look at this look at
this stuff
and yeah this is what happens when you
don't get developed bishop g4 is a
nasty nasty move not allowing this
bishop
to move to any developing squares
h3 he doesn't care rook d1 comes with
tempo
bishop e2 and that is just a pin
and white opted to give up the full
piece rather than the exchange
maybe i would have opted for developing
that bishop and giving up the exchange
but now up a full piece moneyballin
is cruising is cruising here with
uh three extra pawns to go along with
the piece should be a win
for money ballin up next let's check out
21
gigawatts 21
gigawatts nope spelling it wrong
two g's gosh spelling so difficult
all rights what's going on in this game
gigawatts down on the clock
also down numerous pieces but
you know as always as long as those
pawns are on the board
swindling chances remain alive here
so if white makes a queen obviously this
game is blown wide open
but jeru uh jarazelski here probably in
command and control
i think it's time i say to myself well
how did i get here what's going on
where did white's rook go white's rook
went to f6
oh no yeah this was probably the
beginning of the end
i think white just not realizing this
pawn was defended
maybe actually this could have been an
unfortunate mel slip
maybe he intended rick f5 either way 21
gigawatts
down on the position now uh and the
pawns
fall off the board and that will be the
match
jarazelsky probably taking this one home
and what's going on on the final board
we have
tom dear up against spirik
let's see how this is going spirit by
the way i think
the huge underrated player in the
tournament i think
she is definitely one to look out for in
round one by the way she took out mike
cummer
one and a half to a half almost swept
mike and in this game
tom dear unfortunately i'm sure a great
player but
if you know spirit is is taking out mike
cummer then i think he's he's got his
work cut out for him here
uh does tom and in this position it
looks like spirit has
some pretty good chances once again this
is an
absolutely insane pawn structure in the
center by the way
but with the center so closed that means
the wings are going to matter
and is white with the advantage on the
king's side
and i don't think black is really making
up for it with the queen side here
white's rook on f7 has already invaded
looks good
for spirit this bishop has to come all
the way back now
to uh a6 that being said
this night is a little bit awkward i
don't know how spirit is planning
to activate this knight
okay that being said i now am looking at
a ton of games and i see one which is in
a mad time scramble why don't we jump to
it
alex kirford five seconds on the clock
five seconds on the clock against
maurice gp
absolutely no time left for alex i don't
think we're gonna see an insane
time swindle here alex does go down
okay let's check back in on our key
matchups here which of course are these
merits matchups against
express script along with these
enterprise matchups against worldwide
technology
so we saw maybe swap doing well early on
how did maybe swap end up doing
unclear to be honest
and can i pull up the game i think maybe
swaps games are actually
over uh i'm not sure how the second game
went we did see maybe swap
winning in the first round how about
mike mike's game still in progress mike
did take out
his opponent in the first round we saw
him with a good position
let's take a look now at round two mike
playing against
uh n burdek of express scripts
and burdak
and uh is it a good position again i'm
not so
convinced that this one is great for
mike to be honest he does have this
monster knight
on c4 and that being said white did just
capture it
but in return he's given up a lot of
central space and the central space is
not nothing right you know be on the
lookout for white to play moves like e5
and sort of break things open and launch
some kind of attack
that being said i don't think i'm a big
fan of bishop takes knight here i think
this bishop
would have been a great piece back here
on b1 after e5 comes this bishop
is raking across the board and
especially with the queen on c2
we could have seen some nasty
checkmating threats not to be
here today though not it just was not
meant to be
okay um
and i did so much jumping around in the
first round but i feel like i've
found most of the games here i feel like
we've taken a look at almost every
player
to be honest there are a few holdouts
though for example
why don't we take a quick look at neil
esi
playing for express scripts against
mcnick jim who we remember from round
one
uh and what's going on in that game
can i see it here it is all right
mcnick jim looks like he took out neil
esi in the first
round but what is happening here
what is happening here well we have a
slight
imbalance right the pawn structure is
almost perfectly symmetrical
but the main difference is this pawn is
on d5
and black's pawn is on d6 we also now
see white pushing on the queen side as
well
so what does this mean well i think this
imbalance is
actually generally good for black
why is that well with this pawn on d6
black still has good squares for his
pieces on f6 and e5
and with this pawn on d5 it's almost
playing for black
right it's blocking this bishop off this
bishop would love to look at this king
directly
but it really can't get through this
pawn on d5 also this pawn on d5 is going
to be a little bit more vulnerable to
attack than this pawn on d6 that being
said though
still anyone's game we see queen e4
and everybody loves putting this bishop
on b1
and delivering checkmate so we'll see if
we see some of those threats
uh coming up here in this game
very double-edged uh very double-edged
still for both
mcnick and neil esi here
uh let's take another look we do see
that on board one by the way
nick risco the tournament director did
defeat
bayer's board one two to zero tough
break for uh
for bayer there they're gonna have to
work pretty hard to overcome that
deficit
i have to work pretty hard to overcome
that one
um who else have we not seen i don't
think we've seen
paul frowen
um although maybe we actually did
maybe we actually did see paul from
maybe not though let's take a look okay
paul frowan playing against bio proto i
think we also missed in the first round
and paul with an extra exchange here
but i'm i'm a little bit cautious about
his position still
whenever you see a pawn so far up the
board it is
always gonna be too early to call the
game
this pawn two steps away from becoming a
queen and any kind of crazy tactics
uh could happen here uh if i'm black i'm
trying to get this king in
i'm trying to divert this bishop away
from the defense of e2
and if i can manage that i think i have
some pretty good
technical chances here okay we see king
f5 instead i would have liked king f4
just touching this bishop before
capturing this pawn
making this bishop do something with its
life it's looking five notably taking
away a lot of squares from this bishop
bio proto looking to take advantage of
that fact with this last move
rook to uh to g8
and i don't actually see where this
bishop goes
this is sort of an insane position where
i think black's bishop might just be
trapped it can't touch
this square if it touches h7 just rook
g7 and this
bishop will have to come back can't go
this way obviously it can't go
this way the king can't really step out
of the way because the bishop is still
pinned okay rook h8 yeah i
i think bio proto might may have
stumbled into some sort of study-like
position where the bishop
was entirely trapped despite the board
being so open
but instead we do just see a trait of
bishops being offered
and this should also be good for uh
for paul sorry i said the incorrect name
earlier should be good for paul
with the rook and we
should expect him to be able to convert
this these two extra pawns
will have their day in the sun pushing
up the board
a little bit later on in order to win
uh what else is going on well we see
that uh
there's one more game that i want to
take a look at here before we
go back to our main matchups i think
this is the last player that i haven't
taken a look at yet
at least at some point maybe fishers of
men and davenators but you know what you
can't get to everybody there's too many
players
but what's going on with mckenzie
mackenzie probably mckenzie
wow good pronunciations by me
there's also a weird k there though so i
don't know
and i'm typing in the chat instead of
trying to follow
not ideal
and it looks like all of mckenzie's
games are done
against vindy so unfortunately we didn't
get to check that
we did see by the way chess hulky
actually defeating
um dv dutch in a position that i thought
was just good
for dv dutch oh by the way
one more look at this game dn274 i don't
think we've seen yet against eagle eye
oh and this is a tough one weakening
some light squares early on
and it's going to be tough for black to
keep a good hold over
these squares now you can move this
knight out to b8 and
come back to d7 but it is a tough
position already to be sure
i think maybe it's the only move here
which is not very pleasant
not very pleasant at all okay
with that in mind let's check back in
with our key
merits matchups this is what we are
looking at here we have mike
cummer playing against n burdek and mike
is going to be able to convert this one
with these powerful powerful pawns or at
least i hope so
uh there are still some issues with
getting these pawns all the way up the
board
tough to get this pawn to b3 spawn could
get to a2 but not really to a1 just yet
oh and and we see white battling back
with bishop d2 but mike
finds a crucial tactic to pretty much
end the game here this is a skewer
that rook falls off the board on b1 and
mike has this one
in the back on board three for merits
is i am rounder how's i am rounders game
going
well he's launching an attack
launching an attack here yeah expect h3
g4 and if uh rounder can open up this
uh h file black is going to be on the
back foot for sure
black is very much going to be on the
back foot trying to defend this king
it won't be easy what's this though
knight e4 offers a trade of the queens i
wonder if this was on purpose
i don't know if i am rounder realized
black could just trade the queens here
it does make a threat of knight f6 but
yeah first trading the queens
is not bad at all for old loser
and the immediate recapture is correct
but now
bishop takes c4 bishop takes c4 f6
i think black is winning a piece oh but
rook to c8 this allows knight f6
check and all of a sudden white is
winning this exchange but he's only
winning this exchange
back right he had previously sacrificed
in exchange apparently
but you know this is still well worth
taking and then i think with these
bishops um white is going to have a very
comfortable edge here
i would have liked to see bishop takes
b7
f4 i think is actually a really serious
mistake here
it runs into this move of f6 you very
very rarely want to take away
both retreating options for the bishop
and
what happens when you do well your
bishop might get trapped
and i think that's just happening after
the move f6 we'll see
if old loser can find it could be some
controversy
left in this game uh
that being said though why don't we take
a quick look at where we are
standing in this round's results
we do have merits winning
their round against express scripts i am
rounder could be getting into a little
bit of danger
in his game but uh already with a
perfect score on the top two boards
merits are the champions against express
scripts
it's going to be very good for their
standings in the grand prix
uh what's going on with bayer well we
saw that on board one
nick risco did defeat their board one
essentia
uh 2-0 but on all these other boards
things seem to be going pretty much
according to plan
vindi beating mackenzie 2-0 before we
got a chance to look
and so far so good with at least one
point on boards
two through six crest to pj did lose to
ryan in the first round though ryan also
filling in
on that last board there but on boards
two through six
i think that's where this match is going
to be decided with one two oh to
counterbalance
the nick performance on board one
i think bayer has good chances to win
their match as well which leaves us
with the crucial the critical enterprise
worldwide technology matchup we have
a 2-0 for chess hulky against david we
have
a 02 for spirik against tom deere
once again spirit the over performer of
the tournament
winning uh let's see three and a half
out of four games
against tom dear and mike cummer
no pushovers these players um
very good performance from the lowest
rated board for worldwide technology
and then this match is still up in the
air so let's jump to it
how is kamikaze knights game going
let us find out
kamikaze knight crucial game here for
enterprise they need to win this match
to stay in the running
for that uh
that final in december they need to get
in the top four standings in the grand
prix
to qualify and uh this is going to be a
crucial game to decide it this may be
the match
to determine if they can still make
those finals
so what's going on kamikaze knight
definitely pushing
for the win rook a2 is a very nice move
rook b1 i think is forced otherwise he
would have been met with an
awkward c4 interfering with this
knight's defense of the rook
okay e5 is played this obviously doesn't
change the position too much but i think
c4 may have been simpler not bishop c4
but rather um
sorry pawn c4 if i can draw the arrow
and just pushing this pawn in tandem
with the other pawn
is the best way to convert yeah kamikaze
knight definitely just taking
his time here the downside to c4 is it
does actually allow this knight before
idea this
could be why he's delaying this for so
long
and after knight f2 i now see absolutely
no reason
not to play c4 okay kamikaze knight
taking the slow approach
getting the king into the game
definitely nothing wrong with this
either look out for a knight c1 move but
i don't think it's a huge issue after
rook a3
knight b2 i'm pushing this pawn there we
go
finally we do see this pawn coming down
the board
king b4 c3 to follow
and this game is i i think i'm willing
to call it in the bag here
white just cannot move any of their
pieces
tough take the pawn
there's just no moves this knight can't
move
this rook can't move this king could
move but it gets
checked no moves if knight d1 by the way
rook c2 is
checkmate not easy
okay just bishop e4 i would have played
c3 with with
check but this move wins as well it's
all winning for kamikaze knight
by the way big daddy jazz split with
sweet man
one to one excuse me and moneyballin
also scores two zero which leaves just
21 gigawatts against jero zeus
jarazelski and that game has actually
completed
so actually guys i'm looking at the
scores it all depends on this game
for kamikaze knight 26 seconds to
checkmate if kamikaze wins or
draws then enterprise wins the match
scores the 20 points
kamikaze knight loses then worldwide
technology
has drawn this head-to-head matchup
so we see kamikaze knight making a queen
but 19 seconds on the clock
have to go fast by the way the world
junior or the us junior championships
just wrapped up here in st louis and
jeffrey zhang was up a full queen in a
full rook
but flagged in the final game to lose
the match
so it's been done before but it won't be
done here kamikaze knight
too quick finds the checkmate despite
being low on the clock
and with that enterprise wins the match
against worldwide technology
also doing well is bayer uh a critical
game left here is mcnick
jm against neil esi if mcnick jim
jm wins this i think
bayer will be walking away with a
victory
in their buy round against the overflow
players
and that will be huge for them scoring
20 points as well keeping them
up in the running with enterprise with
merits
i think the three teams that needed to
win their matches all won their matches
uh this round assuming all goes well for
bayer
what does that mean well it means we're
going to have a very intense
final corporate chess league uh of
regular season at least in the coming
month so that'll be one to watch where
it all gets determined
uh i think there are six teams very
close in the running
for that uh that top four position and
oof this is a sacrifice but is it a good
one black can just trade the queens
ah but then rook takes f8 okay so black
says you know free rook is free
and takes on f7 the black queen defends
on g6
and we're gonna see black liquidating
now with
some extra material how much extra
material
well uh how about just checkmate and
don't worry about the material
and with that i think the round has come
to
a close uh just kidding is crasta pj
still playing against ryan chester
he is this is the final round ryan
chester
st louis chess club development manager
is
filling in here for some of the players
and is looking to checkmate crash to pj
in absolutely obscene fashion
this is a nasty one look at those
bishops look at this
king what is ryan doing to this guy
my god absolutely
not taking it easy uh on these corporate
chess league players
you know doesn't matter uh if ryan
is is a st louis chess club employee
he's he's here to win
right he may not be representing a team
but he is here to
absolutely annihilate some players
judging by this position
black though is finding ways to hold on
here crass to pj making a
sort of flight square for his king
running away
but ryan takes now this pawn on b7 this
bishop will come back to its central
outpost
and this king just has no squares gonna
be tough here
wow this is i may have to award ryan the
brilliancy prize i didn't award anybody
the brilliancy prize yet
if anybody watching has completed their
games and would like to send in
um a game that they think is deserving
of the award
please do so because you know i've i've
seen some crazy games here today but i
have not
yet awarded a prize i don't think ryan
would be happy
if i gave it to him so i will have to
find somebody else although this game
i think well deserving all observing
what happened here
ryan with the king march up the board
and then all of a sudden
out of nowhere check meeting the black
king crash to pj now down to 23 seconds
king b5 maybe rook b7 check maybe rook
d5
check a lot of tempting options for ryan
the only thing he can't do is go down on
the clock here but i think he has
actually found a checkmate now with rook
b7 rook a5 will come
this bishop guards b2 and this king has
nowhere
to go yeah king a3 but now rook a5
is checkmate and that should conclude
the round
for today these are your final scores
in round two what do we have
we have edward jones continuing their
undefeated streak as expected
um with a victory over ascension in this
uh second round of the day
bad news for ascension tough matchup
we'll see how that affected their grand
p
grand prix standings in a moment
enterprise does
barely defeat uh worldwide technology it
came down to the wire there with
kamikaze
knight clutching it out against mjc with
a victory
chess holkey by the way battling back
against david
uh dv dutch i think chess holkey was in
a bit of trouble with his isolated pawn
but managed to pull something together
to defeat david
big daddy jazz defeating sweet man uh
well actually tying with sweet man
splitting the score there uh moneyballin
uh
getting two points against whedon 80 and
then on the lower boards worldwide
technology made their stand spirit again
i have to say
i think is the the most underrated
player in the event
all she does is win games against higher
rated players
in this game winning against tom dear of
a similar rating
but boy oh boy i'm gonna have to take a
look at that round one game where she
defeated
mike cummer merits with the
with the clean sweep against express
scripts winning on all three of their
boards
the merits team may not have a deep
roster but they have a strong roster
especially here today and so they win
both of their matches
bayer also winning their buy round
defeating the overflow players despite a
strong showing
from the st louis chess club employees
as it should be
ryan and nick both defeating their
opponents two to zero
uh perhaps not the most expected result
but you know a good result
you know for the st louis chess club
proving our worth here
all right let us actually go ahead and
take a look and see
how this has affected our grand prix
standings we have edward jones
still clear atop the list and actually
no
this is after the first round i think
nick
is going to need a moment here in order
to
get the uh the updated totals
or maybe it's on my end again it is on
my end again i had to flip over
to that these are your updated totals we
have edward jones clear atop the list
now
almost double the score of merits who
with two huge wins today has leapfrogged
worldwide technology
into second place wow worldwide with a
bit of a lead coming into today
i did not expect them to drop down to
third but merits
winning both their matches does leapfrog
them into second
enterprise in fourth place with 136
points
and wow oh my god bear a half point out
of making the finals
that is gonna be the story of november's
corporate chess league
ascension by the way only five points
away
from getting to the finals as well those
six teams all
very much in the running for those
finals unfortunately for
express scripts i do think the math is
probably close to eliminating them
but uh very good showing by them here
today as as well
um and for the day what are today's
standings
gonna shake out to be uh we do see
edward jones scoring the most points
increasing their lead
and very good date for enterprise
getting back
in to the that top four they were just
outside
uh coming into today and merits again a
very strong showing by them
uh only three players but the three
players got the job done
bayer and worldwide technology both with
a very decent showing 33 and a half
points
and tough day for ascension and express
scripts although they did score
a few points in their matches
um okay i have to award a brilliant
surprise now
this is something that i neglected to do
earlier on
so i definitely want to take a look
at this spirit game against mike comer i
i get the feeling that this is where
this brilliancy prize is
is going to be going but uh let me pull
up the game here
let me pull up the game if i can might
have to make
some adjustments on the fly to what you
guys are
but this is the game
and i will have to make just a small
little adjustment here
so what happened in this game well
let's take a look we had mike comer with
the white pieces
and she goes for the stone wall okay
mike with an early early early c5 i
don't always like this
because it relieves the pressure on d5
how did
spirit continue she just gets developed
gets castled
queen e8 is a very solid idea in the
stone wall to activate the queen along
this diagonal
okay b4 mike expanding spirit also
expanding
that is a pawn sacrifice mike accepts
but then this attack what about the
attack
though oh my gosh okay a trade on e5 we
see spirit doubling and this is this is
not the attack of an 800 rated player
uh i should say this is the attack of
someone who
has studied some chess rook g3
and rook takes f3 oh my god
don't take that piece don't take that
okay i can't make the move but don't
take that piece queen g1 is
mate king e1 played the queen comes in
with
check rook takes f4
and the sacrifices continue oh my gosh
this is brutal we see mike getting
checked all over the board and then
queen g3
hitting a rook hitting rook b3 winning
the queen
and then she just converts this
effortlessly
okay maybe with some effort but still
converts it
that is checkmate and mike cummer goes
down that is without a doubt
the brilliancy prize for the event
congratulations
to spirik the prize is i believe
uh i was informed it's a lesson with me
so if you're interested
reach out to ryan or lauren they'll hook
you up with the details there
um what an event overall guys i had such
a blast
commentating on the event let me flip
back to our total standings
this is where we stand after today's
action edward jones still in first
merits
worldwide technology enterprise bayer
ascension all in the running
for those finals all in pretty good
position
to get into the finals in december uh i
had a lot of fun
covering all the action here today uh
hopefully
you guys enjoyed as well if you want to
go back through and watch any of the
action it will be saved here on the
youtube channel
i think i got to almost every player
there might have been one or two
holdouts
that i didn't catch so uh hopefully
though
it was enjoyable for you guys that is
going to do it for me here tonight
once again thank you all so much for
joining my name is caleb denby
and i will see you hopefully next month
thank you guys and good bye